I mean what you guys the fat fight have
done with your platform is truly amazing
and I I think about jvn you know
obviously he just opened up about his
HIV diagnosis was it hard for you to
watch that and did you know beforehand
before he showed that news with the
world yeah we all knew it we are where
we know the five of us are very close
and we talked about it many times a long
time before and we've always been
supportive you know for me I used to
have an hiv/aids organization to end
stigma and so he was very comfortable
and talking about it it's something that
we have to talk about because it just
says it in effect the LGBT community it
affects African Americans it affects all
of us it affects kids and the more we
talk about is the more people will get
help get treatment was that a hard
decision for him to make to be and go
public with it um you know I can't speak
on his decision to make to go public
with it I'm just proud of the fact that
he has because it's something that his
visibility is helping so many other
people to feel comfortable in who they
are
let's about Dancing with the Stars are
you having a ball no pun intended but
are you having the best time I have even
more of a ball when I win that mirror
ball you know I'm having a great time
I'm somebody who likes costumes I like
it all and the fact that each week
there's also like tons of celebrities in
there literally two nights ago
Demi Lovato was like I'm in love with
you and I'm just like Demi Lovato what
are you kidding me and so it's just kind
of an honor to have people that I've
looked up to for so long
constantly tell me how much they look up
to me in environment it's been the most
surprising part of the whole experience
for you is that just having rhythm is
not enough because I thought I could
slide through having rhythm having style
but it's like hard hard and there's a
couple people who are ringers because
they've had dancing experience I'm not a
hater but I'm like seems a little unfair
and so I'm like hold on I have to work a
little bit harder to keep up with these
people who've been dancing since they
were three years old doing it you do I
am I feel confident we're celebrating
100 years of Save the Children I mean
how important was it for you to be here
and support the cost tonight I mean it's
always important I mean when we think
about how many kids are on this world
who don't have access to food education
housing supportive parents
you have to come and do whatever you can
to support them and as a father myself
it's like my boys are the world to me so
I always want to make sure that other
children have the same things that my
kids have it's kind of amazing karma
because as famous as you're getting and
as successful and which is also all
deserve you've also given and dedicate
yourself to causes are important to you
to give back why is that so important I
mean well first of all I'm a black gay
man living in America and there is a lot
of things that are wrong with our
country right now from the bottom to the
top and so when it comes to causes when
it comes to political affiliations I
feel like I have to lend whatever
celebrity whatever public opinion I can
to be a voice for those who can't be in
spaces like this because right now we
have people who are definitely trying to
silence us silence children silence
people of color silence people the
LGBTQIA community and that's not okay
with me
[Music]